chilly date the ballpark happy mother's
day everyone
with adam wainwright you know a lot of
curveballs
and usually win right very efficient
getting second in the lineup
is right into betting trevor's story the
pitch to story is hit hard toward third
picked on one hop by arenato
and he throws out his good friend trevor
story this guy is worth
the price of admission because it plays
like this
1-1 pitch is popped up
orinato on the outfield grass puts it
away at a one two three for adam
wainwright with a little help from his
third baseman come on marquez
it's ready to make uh start number eight
he begins with the switch hitter tommy
edmonds breaking ball
is hit to the left side backhanded by
story long throw
and got him on a good stretch by connor
joe
third story circled and still had to
backhand that ball edmond of course
runs well his pick at first by joe one
guy paul goldschmidt the hitter
throw to first and it gets by connor
jill
it rolls down enough that carlson is
heading for
third the throw and he is out by 10 feet
connor joe hustled that ball down over
by the
tarp up against the grandstand and he
unleashed a throw and it was not
close at all so two runners on nobody
out
this hitting an even 200 here's a 1-1
curveball lined arenado puentes should a
line drive to his cousin for out number
one the catcher today
diaz back to him knocked it down with
time
out there the turn double play adam was
quick to react
coronado facing his old team marinado
out to deep left field his first home
run against his former team
watched it into the bullpen you know
he's loving it
such a good at bat for arenado
and it was set up by him taking those
two fastballs that were just
off the plate it got the count in his
favor
and he got to see a lot of pitches and
finally got one
more in the middle of the plate and that
was a home run of the
line drive variety rydell tapia
a bunk has been called on wainwright 3-2
pitch
he does and a called third strike first
strikeout for adam wainwright
he absolutely dotted that inside corner
so it's trevor storey at the plate
swinging at a miss struck him out
back-to-back case with a runner at third
top of the fourth inning connor joe and
the next from mueno
fastball outside corner strike three
wainwright
picks up strikeout number three the
second one caught looking
bottom of the fourth molina will bet
there's a line drive the left base hit
for yadier molina
arenado rounds second he's going to
third that goes all the way to the wall
pop warner is sending him we're gonna
have a play at the plate
wide throw he's safe aronado scores from
first
on the double by yadier molina and it's
two-nothing
cardinals pop warner
was thinking aronado you're going to
score when the ball
split tapia and dazza going to the wall
carlson single to left and walked on
base twice
another base hit for dylan carlson on
base for the third time
if things keep going like this he's
going to be the rookie of the year we're
a long ways away but man oh man
he's putting together a heck of a rookie
campaign
orinato is two for two here's a swing
and a high
fly ball that goes into center arnotto
just missed that pitch he threw the bat
down after
making contact and dazza makes the catch
big
inning here sixth inning tapia at second
base
ryan mcmahon to the pitch mcmahon lifts
a fly ball
left center field it's not hit very deep
at all under at bader
he makes the catch and tapia goes back
to second two outs runner at second base
here in this
sixth inning getting hotter
vader on the move and he'll make the
catch
he caught it about five feet away from
the warning track with a great jump
yachty pulls it fair off the sidewall
is he thinking two he is go on in there
yachty sliding in with his second double
of the day
[Applause]
his family and mom they love it he just
got that one passed
josh puentes he is always a difference
maker
yadier molina 7th inning it's connor joe
leading
things off here's a 1-1
back to wayne oh and joe is retired oh
for two of the walk
wainwright is in control the o2 delivery
curveball is hit
in the air backing up a step or two is
tommy edmond the cardinals second
baseman to make the play
elias diaz will bat
hanging breaking ball lifted in the air
to left center bader there
diaz retired six in a row for wayne oh
top of the eighth inning adam wainwright
still in this game the one-two pitch
check swing and he went strikeout number
four
seven in a row yadi stepping out in
front of the play to allow this crowd
to give a nice ovation to matt adams and
he hits the first pitch off the foot of
adam wainwright who kicks it towards
first
and he doesn't panic picks it up and
throws out adams
that's a veteran play right there and
he's smiling
he kicked it in the right direction
didn't he it was a little soft ground
ball and he kicked it
but he didn't panic bear handed it and
he got adam's
adam wainwright is pitching for his
second complete game this year he is
something else
trevor story wind up the 3-2 pitch curve
ball swung on and missed he got him
five strikeouts for wainwright two
involving trevor story
one out runner at first and charlie
blackman
three and one on blackman ball four up
and away
and the tying run is at first he's gonna
take him out right here but what a gutsy
performance by adam wainwright big big
start right here for him
only two hits that's been it he gave up
a double to charlie blackman
in the second inning and then tapia
in the sixth inning a base hit to center
eight and a third adam wainwright big
hand come for adam wainwright who worked
eight in the third innings
ryan helsley gets the call now the base
is loaded for the rockies
josh fuentes ground ball to the
shortstop
to second out onto first double play in
a redbird winner
the young to edmond to goldschmidt
and this ball game has come to an end
with fuentes grounding into a 6-4-3
double play
adam wainwright gets the win beating him
on marquez and the cardinals
have swept the rockies